hey guys it's justine and today i am
beauty guru ij because we are talking
about
animal crossing and colourpop they did a
collaboration together for this
really cool line of cosmetics a huge
thank you to nintendo for sending me all
of this to check out it's all animal
crossing themed i'm actually wearing
some of it right now i just shot an
entire
kind of makeup video in my bathroom oh
boy oh
boy so i will be intercutting throughout
this video some makeup demos from
the bathroom but this stuff is so cute
like take a look at it it's just
i'm so excited because i love this game
so much and i'm not much of a makeup
person the makeup that i wear on a
day-to-day basis
i've been wearing the same thing
probably for
almost like eight years i just i got the
foundation down i got the eye like it's
just
it never changes this is so exciting i
actually
saw this on instagram when they posted
it and lost
my mind and today it's here and we're
gonna check it out
okay so tom nook says i had these made
especially for island residents
now we all know that that's a lie
because tom does not
do things for people he just takes your
money
takes your bells rips you off he's a
crook
oh a note colour pop x
animal crossing new horizons create your
own diy
island makeup look we've got some little
stickers
fruit roots just a tint mini duo
this is a peach surprise and orange
cutie because you know if you grow fruit
the fruit trees that you grow what a
good idea
coconuts and pear apple
and cherry so cute this is cool
oh and here's the the little color
palettes
it says true friends oh my gosh there's
a lot of stuff in here the billionaire
glitter something i don't know what's in
there yet we don't know
this is balloon pop super shock shadow
flower tender pressed powder blush
oh freaking fancy hello
and this one is flower power also
pressed powder blush where do we even
start i already have an excessive amount
of blush on already
because that's just who i am as a person
but i think we're gonna put a little
more pink on can you even tell like
there's so much light in here
it's probably gonna make it
hard to see maybe we need a little more
all right i'll put a little more
this is really pretty i really like this
color
i also really like this color too it's
more of a
i guess a little bit more of an orange
kind of a salmony
undertone very excited about this i'm
actually wearing the flower power and
then i put this
flower tender flower tender
flower power flower tender i use this as
kind of like a little uh i guess contour
bronzer like the packaging is incredible
like colourpop do you guys want to do
like a collab
with me i like this color a lot it's
like a really nice kind of shimmery pink
okay flower tender a nice tender flower
let's check this one out so this is more
of like a
it's like a peachy kind of color i
probably would also wear this as a blush
but since i already had the pink on i
thought this was like a little bit more
of a bronze color
so i did a little bronzing around my
face
i want to do something cool with my eye
shadow
okay that is so purple i'm gonna just
add this
as like a little liner
do i look different do i look like a
different person i mean
it's definitely purple can you see it
what do you think does it look cool i
think it looks cool so i was using this
as a liner and i'm gonna use this kind
of
i don't know i don't know what i'm gonna
put it i'm just gonna put it on my
eyelid and see what happens
yeah that's a nice crease color i mean i
feel
like a freaking princess
of the island i'm princess of the island
true friends i love the packaging
it's beautiful so we have labelle of the
ball nook
inc five star island and what a hoot
here's our colors we've got abel sisters
taylor's ticket
custom design and serene sable so these
are the two that i'm wearing this is in
my crease and i've got this one
kind of as a liner next we have nook ink
these colors are uh
they're a little green not really sure
that these colors are something that i
would wear on a daily basis but they are
actually very very pretty colors we've
got yes yes
made in the shade ceo and water landing
such cute names next we have five star
island
this has a little isabelle themed these
are actually really
really pretty colors more of a pink hue
we've got isabelle
island tune island designer and resident
rep
next up we've got what a hoot this is
really pretty so these are some more
type of like a brown and like a bronzy
type hues
we have meteor shower celestial olive
flutter and who
i just i can't get over it i think i
like makeup now
what do i think is it a vibe
i think it is now i kind of need
this balloon pop super shock shadow i'm
gonna use this as a highlighter
i've already got an excessive amount of
highlighter on right now but
i'm just gonna add that as like a little
little added bonus
i don't even think you guys can see what
i'm doing but wow there's a lot of
glitter on my face now
i'm gonna put that in my brow look at
that wow
okay maybe i should have put that in my
eyebrows but that's a little excessive
now that i have glitter everywhere let's
see what color
we would like to do for for the lips
this one looks good i probably do like a
little pink or something
that looks like a color i might wear oh
my god it smells so good
this smells like an apple it smells like
an actual apple that smells like an
actual cherry
holy moly
okay i love this color
oh man have i just become
have i become a beauty guru overnight i
love that they have
these three sets of color pop lip tints
i'm not much of one to wear much color
on my lip but if i do
i'd like to have sort of a transparent
kind of glossy kind of look
and these are like perfect i was very
surprised because the consistency and
also
the flavor of these are incredible so
they have three different little lip
gloss sets and there's
two of them in each these are just
really cute i can't get over it
and the fact that i've already used them
and i'm in love with them is even more
exciting
so this is one of my favorites the juicy
apple and cherry cherry
let's open these up
and it smells like a freaking apple as
well
just a tint coconut and pear
got some darker kind of brown hues which
are very nice
i just like that like it is just a tint
just a what a tint
these these are some nice colors as well
these are like a nude
kind of color and here's all our gloss
colors
love oh
wow okay this looks nice so here's my
final look
what do you think do i even look that
different i really i hardly ever wear
eyeshadow but i actually really like
this
also i think i could probably use this
as like a little bronzer as well
i'm ready to visit an island now
oh okay hello who is she
she's me i forgot to try
the glitter i don't really have a place
that i can put this on my face right now
let's just do a little hand test here
whoa whoa
whoa that is
so shining shimmering and splendid
so i think that this is my favorite i
love this this is the little bellionaire
so it's basically
a pot of glitter but it looks like a pot
of gold
you know belle themed money it's got a
little cute
like gold star on it beautifulness like
this is incredible
this smells like high school to me like
i used to wear glitter all the time
like this like like this is this is
taking me back to high school
i can't believe it wow but this looks so
cool i don't think that this is
something that i could wear
necessarily every single day like a
daily basis like
like a daily wear but tell you what
justine circa 2008
music video she would have definitely
wore that for some casual music video
parodies huge fan of this this is a
color pop
balloon pop obviously if you've played
animal crossing then you're going to get
all of these
references this is a really pretty
shadow gloss i guess it's not really a
gloss but it has like a
what is this i don't know it's like um i
can't even i don't know it's like a pot
of
beauty it's a pot of beauty but like
look
look at that shimmer freaking wow well
guys thank you for watching i'm so
excited about this collection i'll put a
link in the description if you want to
check it out and again a huge thank you
to nintendo for sending me this this is
honestly really really cool
and now i kind of i kind of want to
experiment with
like some makeup look out you guys might
just see some
some new looks coming at you i'll be
serving them
alright i'll see you later bye i've got
stuff all over
i've got makeup everywhere
you